[Music]
george floyd's tragic death led to
promises to tackle structural racism
across the world and to make black lives
better
so over a year later what progress is
being made in tackling racism amongst
the police
two chicago police officers ran up to
him slammed him against a brick wall and
smashed his head onto the sidewalk more
than once
we have to make sure that this police
department reflects the needs of the
community
what is required to address racial
injustice in education systems
black students are three times more
likely than white students to be
suspended or expelled from school and
this has serious consequences
and why are there still not enough black
faces in positions of corporate power
it's completely inefficient to exclude
40 of the labor market from your
management jobs because you're going to
be excluding very good people
andre can you hear me my name is jerry
with the madison police department these
officers from madison's police force are
being trained in de-escalation
techniques well can you come out and
talk to me a little bit dude i'm in my
house
not bothering anybody
black americans are nearly three times
more likely than whites to die at the
hands of the police
many in the u.s see policing as the
front line of racial injustice
and believe improving black lives starts
with improving policing you seem like
you feel like you are being taken
advantage of
because that woman in that house is
still for me
you know what the the phone that she
used to call you on guess what dude
i paid for that i'll pay for that phone
there's been many incidents that have
occurred here in america that has really
caused policing to take a second look at
itself and quite frankly it's long
overdue
traditional policing tactics have
prioritized the safety of officers and
the need to seize control of situations
quickly
a little different 20 years ago when we
started when you're told you got to get
control of the situation as soon as
possible
but now these officers are learning to
pause and assess situations before
taking action the biggest thing i'd want
our officers to to learn and to know is
just to to focus on slowing things down
research by psychologists at stanford
has found that slowing down can reduce
the harms caused by implicit bias
in police departments snap judgments can
be made when things are going quickly
and by training police officers to slow
the moment down to slow down the events
we can actually help reduce implicit
bias and reduce negative incidences
the strategy of pausing to reflect has
produced positive results
the year after its introduction in
oakland california the number of black
drivers stopped by police dropped by 45
percent
stronger relations with black american
communities also require police training
that better reflects the demands of the
job
the majority of policing situations
demand an ability to communicate
[Music]
can you come out and talk to me for a
second step away from the hammers
[Music]
from police dramas to westerns american
popular culture has a long history of
glorifying the gun-toting law and order
cop
[Music]
but an analysis of three police forces
found that on average only four percent
of their time was spent dealing with
violent crime he's concerned about you
right now where is he can i see him
and thirty percent of police time
involves incidents where no crime has
been committed such as domestic disputes
but i understand the situation that you
are in no you don't
need an action situation
around 10 of police cases relate to
people suffering a mental health crisis
is it possible for you to put the knife
on the ground for now
it makes me feel safer i can't i i'm not
gonna hurt anybody else i can't i can't
do that
well i would hope that the public would
appreciate how deliberate we are trying
to be with respect to active listening
recognizing a lot of calls that police
officers go to are not quick fixes get
out
get out the car get out man i have not
committed any crime
but changing the attitudes of police
towards black communities will be hard
compared with whites black americans are
five times more likely to get arrested
they are three times more likely to get
killed by the police i'm honestly afraid
to get out yeah you should be
i have a
a 12 year old son
and the reason i wear this uniform the
reason i took this position
is because i need to ensure
that no parent
feels what i'm feeling right now
their parents having a conversation with
their child and thinking
if they're 10 minutes behind curfew are
they okay
and they're not worried about being
robbed or they're not worried about car
being stolen they're worried about what
will happen if their son is stopped by
the police
and that is a reality
for black people in america
trust in the police has long been lower
amongst black americans than whites
after the murder of george floyd in
minneapolis by a police officer black
americans confidence in the police fell
to an all-time low of just 19 percent
[Applause]
this helped fuel a campaign to defund
police forces
tonight with a mounting national chorus
declining police brutality against black
americans there's a new call for deep
structural reform of policing across the
country many are now demanding
departments be defunded dismantled or
outright abolished
[Music]
only one city camden in new jersey has
abolished its police force and started
from scratch
and many defund the police advocates are
not arguing for this they want resources
diverted away from the police towards
tackling the root causes of crime it
does not give our communities the
resources that they actually need from
the things that would actually keep us
safe not cops
the defund the police movement
is a movement that is probably better
described as a reallocation of funding
rather than a taking away of funding
many advocates in this movement want
those funds to go to the community to
focus on other things like mental health
and homelessness and housing
the idea behind this reform is to
empower communities to live lives where
they are less affected by police
interventions
well the united states has vast problems
with racial relations and they permeate
almost every aspect of our society from
fair housing integrated housing quality
schools it's just essential that we not
lose sight of the fact that we are
trying to solve the country's problems
with the police and badges and guns
don't solve social problems
back in madison this is an approach
favored by local activist brandy grayson
i have a pessimistic view of policing as
a model for serving our people
we need a system that's for the people
by the people that consider the people
that's most impacted and vulnerable to
poverty but with eighteen thousand
different law enforcement agencies in
the u.s pushing through reform is a tall
order
fox news alert minneapolis voters say no
to a measure that would have dismantled
their police department
the climate has changed since the
aftermath of george floyd's death in
2020 with resistance to change emerging
so cities across the country are seeing
a major spike in violent crime now
there was a rush of enthusiasm to do
something that needed to be done
but now with rising crime rates with
pressure from police unions
from uncertainty in the public about
what the right answers are i think it's
getting a little harder to effect some
of the reforms that are desperately
needed
it's not just america where black people
are over-represented in the criminal
justice system
in england and wales just over three
percent of the population are black
yet nearly 13 of people in prison are
black
one way to address this
over-representation is to reduce the
number of black students who are
excluded from schools
people who drop out of school or are
pushed out of school are more likely to
become incarcerated so when we talk
about the school-to-prison pipeline what
we're saying is that
when black students make the same
mistakes as white students they're more
likely to end up getting involved in the
criminal justice system that is an
example of structural racism that has an
impact today
in 2018 89 of children in young offender
institutions in england and wales had
been excluded from school
and in england if you're a student from
an afro-caribbean background you're four
times more likely to be excluded than a
white british peer kieran gill advised
on a government report about exclusion
even when statisticians control for
other factors that are at play for those
young people like poverty or geography
they still find a statistically
significant disproportion for certain
ethnic groups
the people that are meeting up my peers
is
this feeling that they're outside
stefan campaigns with the charity just
for kids law to end school exclusions
yeah
they're not even out
then
we don't belong in society
at the age of 12 he became one of the
nearly 450 000 children who get
temporarily or permanently excluded from
english schools each year
i was a kid that learned in a different
way
and to school see as misbehaved or badly
behaved
you've got this black boy misbehaving
and a lot of teachers that don't come
from a place that you come from will say
it's a sign of aggression and they won't
tolerate it
for many excluded students their
disruptive behavior often stems from
difficult home lives
i never had a childhood my childhood was
based on
gang members
[Music]
drugs
robin et cetera et cetera
i was really being outcrossed by so many
different places and being outcrossing
school
that is a very
terrible thing
many of the black students who get
excluded live in high crime inner city
neighborhoods if they're not in school
who do you think they're gonna leave it
they're gonna be with
the drug leaders
the killers the whatever you wanna name
whatever name you wanna put to them they
want to be with them type of people
in the majority of cases falling out of
education potentially means a long life
of challenge of interaction with crime
of mental ill health and of struggles in
interpersonal relationships it's just
too important an issue to say we can't
do anything about this
[Music]
one city in britain has done something
about reducing exclusions
this isn't roach's school in glasgow 15
years ago it excluded around 300 pupils
a year for something we can do you need
to let us know and then we'll try and do
what we can to help
but then a new policy was implemented
with the agreement of the headmaster
and in recent years only a handful of
students have been excluded
it's important that you get all your
homework done and get studying but you
need to take time for yourself as well
and you've got to get the balance out so
you get some time to relax
exclusions for us are very much
an absolute last resort and the reason
for that is because we don't think that
exclusions solve any problems
the school has invested in training its
teachers to better understand and
support students displaying behavioral
issues
we have a real need to find out what is
lying behind
poor behavior and if we can understand
what is leading to that then we can
tackle the root cause rather than the
symptom of the bad behavior in school
you can kind of see some of the kids who
come in the morning from challenging
backgrounds or kids who have low
confidence or low self-esteem may
struggle early in the morning
this approach was implemented
systematically across glasgow's schools
in 2010
the results for children of all ethnic
backgrounds have been positive
between 2010 and 2015 youth crime in the
city fell by 50 percent i don't have any
evidence to say well because you've
reduced exclusions
that's what's happened with youth crime
but they must be linked if we have more
young people getting more qualifications
able to make more positive choices in
their lives
able to be the next generation of
positive families then everybody wins
don't they
reducing exclusions can help tackle
structural racism within education
systems
and it can save governments and
taxpayers lots of money
in england each cohort of permanently
excluded pupils costs an extra 2.1
billion pounds over their lifetime in
education health welfare and criminal
justice costs
it costs 18 000 pounds to send an
excluded child to an alternative
provision school compared with around 6
000 in mainstream education
i've heard from everyone's tutors and
it's really clear that all of you are
already making a difference in ways big
and small kieran gill runs a charity
which aims to bring the benefits of
glasgow's policy to the school system in
england
we run programmes with
teachers who want to become heads one
day and we take them for two years to
work in a school for excluded students
in a leadership position and they also
learn so much more about multi-agency
working mental health effective support
for families and after two years they
take that expertise back to a mainstream
school in a senior leadership position
where they can shape the strategy of
what that school is going to do
[Music]
improving the experiences of black
children within education systems will
have far-reaching benefits
it could help give black people a better
chance of getting ahead in the corporate
world
while black workers make up twelve point
nine percent of the labor force in
america
at the senior manager and vice president
level they make up just five percent and
at the senior vice president level just
four percent at the very top only around
one percent of fortune 500 ceos are
black
there's been very little progress on
diversifying the corporate work
managerial workforce since the late
1980s
the numbers are
they're just
they're so depressing
the solution may not be the one many
companies turn to after george floyd's
death
and this afternoon 8 000 starbucks
stores across the country will close to
train employees on racial bias if you
are a racist barista at starbucks good
news you've got about a month left to
while out
unconscious buyers training may sound
like the right policy for companies to
adopt
but it has long proved to be ineffective
what happens is that some people think
okay we're fixed and so they don't pay
attention to the problem anymore and
other other people are aggravated
and they they think that they've been
unfairly blamed for being racist or
sexists it's astonishing to me that
companies are still throwing so much
money at this clearly failed approach
for us to actually see progress being
made
we have to step away from easy banding
solutions
and focus on root causes
for this disparity
the evidence shows that trying to change
the attitudes of individuals within
companies doesn't work
but changing systems does
companies that put in formal mentoring
programs that are open to everybody they
see huge increases in the diversity
of the management population after five
or ten years
when we look at black men and women
their numbers in management increase
after companies put in
child care programs flexibility programs
and parental leave programs
companies with more diverse managerial
teams also tend to do better
management consultancy firm mckinsey
found that companies that did best on
cultural diversity were 36 percent more
likely to outperform financially those
that did worse
despite this
many companies are reluctant to invest
in the necessary reforms
these things are harder than hiring a
diversity trainer who will come in and
do a session and
who will then just go away and let you
continue to do business as usual
[Music]
improving the opportunities for black
people to take up management positions
will help close the racial wealth gap
increasing the numbers of successful
black entrepreneurs will also help
reduce this gap across the world
that means white investors in rich
countries being more willing to back
businesses run by black people
including those in east africa
nairobi in kenya has been dubbed the
silicon savannah with its booming tech
sector
kenya is now cited as one of the most
plugged in countries on the african
continent anteshimbabu is one of many
freewheeling tech entrepreneurs
with a drive to succeed
and an appetite for risk
i am tasha babu an even more adventurous
spirit and a technology entrepreneur
you have over 1.3 billion people in the
continent
so it just shows that the potential over
the next
decade is is just unfathomable
[Music]
so we're on our way to kangami which is
one of the small t
ethnic slums with over 100 000 people so
we'll be meeting nemo who's one of our
merchants she's been doing very well the
last couple of weeks so love to talk to
her and hear how she's doing
tesh has launched an app now used by
more than 25 000 retail outlets like
this one
so what we do simply is help mom and pop
stores to reorder for their inventory
digitally and conveniently throw up
as well as earn extra income by acting
as distribution agents for popular
financial services like bill payments
but like many black entrepreneurs here
he has struggled to attract investment
from wealthy countries
in 2019 only six percent of the money
invested in kenyan fintech startups went
to those founded by local kenyans
the vast majority went to startups
founded by expats
yes i'd say it's been a challenge for
most africans there's quite a gap
between the entrepreneur on the ground
who's building talking to customers
and
the people with access to capital that
are supposed to finance you
part of the problem is a lack of black
investors
most venture capital firms are
concentrated in the us and europe
one analysis found that less than one
percent of these firms have black owners
raising money is about who do i know
because before i invest in the business
or the idea i'm investing in the person
more bridges between western investors
and black african entrepreneurs are
needed
i think then we should also
write to the investor for interest
and that's the focus of this angel
investment consultancy firm in kenya
the markets here are not what they are
in the west you have cultural issues you
have challenges with infrastructure and
that just means that businesses grow in
a much slower pace one and it takes much
more cash to get a business to unicorn
status or to that kind of africa-wide
company
it also trains local entrepreneurs in
how to present their ideas to western
investors
i will say some of the skills that we
think are quite lacking especially when
it comes to very young entrepreneurs is
the whole idea of explaining or
articulating their ideas properly
[Music]
we can never be satisfied as long as the
negro is the victim of the unspeakable
horrors of police brutality
racial injustice carries different
historical burdens across the world
the solutions are complex and various
but the benefits would be felt beyond
black communities
one estimate found that structural
racism had cost america over 70 trillion
dollars in lost output since 1990
nevertheless big questions remain about
the collective appetite to make black
lives better the idea behind structural
racism
is that racism is built into the systems
and policies
of a country or a society when we're
asking ourselves
how do we get rid of racism
how do we make society more equitable we
have to focus on the people in power
politicians ceos
school leaders and others
it's those men and women who are key to
changing systems
and when the systems change
so perhaps will attitudes and outcomes
hi i'm tamara jokes 4 u.s policy
correspondent at the economist if you
would like to read more about race then
please click on the link and if you'd
like to watch more of our now and next
series please click on the other link
thank you for watching and please do not
forget to subscribe